hello and welcome to swipe coming up we
take a walk on the cyber wild side
exploring the world of animal robotics
ok glass no record we try out a pair of
google glasses precise the wearable tech
race speeds up as Sony throws its hat or
wig into the ring and we are taking a
look at some of the top titles available
for handheld devices the animal kingdom
has been inspiring us for quite some
time now studying the behavior and
biology of other species has helped us
design aircraft textiles wind turbines
and even velcro that thanks to the buzz
on a dog's coat so it comes as no
surprise that scientists are also
turning to the natural world to enhance
and evolve the field of Robotics skies
gem and water supports a perfect
humanoid may still be a long way off in
the world of robotics but in the
meantime engineers have been making the
most of some other species for ideas
robot Safari exhibition at the Science
Museum is part of the growing
recognition of wildlife inspired
robotics from a diverse field of
disciplines meet Robo spider built to
help further research of arachnids it's
also a tool to help children learn how
to code in our country it's growing
contestants in robotics
this little small example like the
spider shows that the robotics can be
applied anywhere mimicking animal
behavior means roboticists have a much
broader set of skills to work with for
example replicating the physiology and
movement of a sea turtle means these
aqua BOTS can explore dangerous
underwater wrecks that are too risky for
human divers I think the main reason for
a studying nature he said it's like it
big big freely available patent database
actually you have billions of years to
try our door sort of solutions and some
of them might work some of Saint own but
they definitely give you inspiration how
to solve any particular problem it's an
area which is constantly evolving
attracting interest from a range of
sectors from agriculture to the military
but it's not without its growing pains
we do have robots that can walk like
animals on uneven surfaces but we don't
have anything with the agility say of a
dog or a cat so there's a huge amount of
problems to be solved and it's not going
to be solved just by making faster
computers we have to actually understand
the biological systems better salamandra
robotica this is used by neurobiologist
to study the nervous system of early
vertebrates has taken ten years to get
to this stage but it's still a long way
off some of its more ambitious goals we
hope that in very long-term this can
help understanding even how human work
and and so on to get better
understanding of the spinal cord and
possibly to have some treatments for
repair projects and so on but we are
very very far from that the progress is
certainly exciting but it may take
scientists just a little while longer to
catch up with mother nature completely
Gemma Morris Sky News you're watching
swype coming up we meet the company
that's making 3d printed dolls but first
no dates having Google glass we top this
year's fantasy festive wish list of
quite a few of you tech geeks out there
the specs have been one of the most
talked about items from 2013 and
miss came early to the sweat team this
week as we managed to get our hands and
appear skies fill up a whole tried them
on for size so these are them the google
glass this is them simple just put it on
just like a normal pair of glasses well
I do wear glasses so yeah it's just saw
what I mean we're still developing us
I'm kind of expecting this to feel quite
familiar ok glass record a video ok sit
start straight away you go you can press
the camera button to extend the time
this is gonna be 10 seconds unless i
press this button or just pressed it at
nine seconds and that keeps recording
that's right show me what else it can do
so you can if you're in a foreign
country and you want to see you in Spain
yeah and you want to be less in Japan
that's me more complicate it you're in
Japan you don't speak any Japanese I see
you know why don't you ask it where is
the station in Japanese so all you do is
you'd say ok that's ok glass Google how
do I say where is the station in
Japanese
so now work with google translate and it
should be saying it in your ear through
the head I heard it's strange cuz you
hear it just behind the ear that's right
so how do I get it to play it again
because I need to check my pronunciation
so you tap and you can tap again it'll
read it aloud to you EQI go Curtis yeah
aqui y doko desu soo ok ok one more cool
thing that this can do that I should
know about you can ask it to tell you
where the nearest cinema is if you're
looking to get the cinema tonight ok
let's see if I believe this so be ok ok
class yes directions to get directions
to cinema cinema wonderful does it was
her Barney popcorn and since Ottomans
nearest one to you they didn't know that
one can i preorder thing yeah I'll one
day who knows one day send your favorite
sweets and they'll have it there on the
well so now you know it's very wearable
technology move your head leave my head
oh my goodness orienta where you are so
you'll see that actually you never get
something good to go this yeah cool got
a long way to go but that's it and so
there you go you're watching swype
coming up Apple cleans up at the Pocket
lint awards but first as part of a new
series here in swype we are taking a
look at our technology is boosting
British business and helping new
startups Mickey lab in East London is
one company that's taking advantage of
advances in 3d printing to make more
unique toys making lab is a toys and
games company based in Shoreditch in
London and we make the world's first 3d
printed toys I think the mission of
making lab is to make toys and games
better in every way you can make a makie
on the web or you can make your makey on
an iPad and basically what you do is you
open up the app or you open up the
website and then you edit the face and
you can edit anything on the face from
the eyes the distance between the eyes
the nose the mouth the duel the hair the
ears and then we take it into the little
workshop put the clothes on click all
the pieces together because everything
kind of pops off as very component-based
slide it into a tube put the certificate
in with it and then send it out
all of our dolls are 3d printed and the
thing that that achieves for us is it
means that we can make everything on
demand and we make things really quickly
so somebody in our forum can ask for a
crown or a bag or a belt and we can have
it in the shop by the end of the week
this completely changes everything in
terms of how quick we can be and how
much we can make so the breadth of the
things that we make is much broader
because we can do whatever we want
really quickly I think that as we scale
it would be really good to actually put
in place the local manufacturer that
we've been talking about so printing
dolls for north america in north america
and you know dolls for japan in japan so
that we can see the benefits of the
technology so that there's less waste
there's less shipping and we can make
that big change which is something that
the toy industry needs i think you're
watching swype coming up switch off your
console we review some of the best games
for handhelds but first he has a roundup
of anything you might have missed over
the last few days shawnee there's a
latest company to enter the wearable
tech race filing a patent application
for a smart wig no longer just for the
follicly challenged it will apparently
be able to process data and communicate
wirelessly with other external devices
it'll even get you home and take your
blood pressure who knows it could even
win over a few fashionistas I haven't
liked some of the more sartorially
challenged bits of wearable tech Bitcoin
has been breaking records this week
according to one of the major exchanges
for the virtual currency a single
bitcoin has for the first time surpass
the one thousand dollar mark that's 613
pounds a bitcoin confidence in the
currency has grown since it was
described as quartz a legitimate
financial service at a US Senate
committee hearing Apple has bought the
3d sensing company primeSense it paid
260 million pounds for the Israeli
company which specializes in sensing
tick that all those devices to observe a
scene in three dimensions it's again
fueling speculation that Apple is
developing its own motion sensing device
perhaps even some form of gesture
control for that much anticipated Apple
TV
no TV has been named this year's best
home entertainment device and the Pocket
lint gadget awards powered by sky and
firing through broadband it's here to
give you the most amazing content out
there the crossroads of screens the box
which is powered by sky and tons your
telly into a smart TV was one of the big
winners at the annual celebration of the
year's finest tech winning in the
wearable tech category was the super
smart pebble wristwatch HTC one was
named this year's best mobile phone
Apple's 13-inch MacBook here was named
best laptop and the ipad air was named
best tablet and this year's best product
an advert for engineering toys for girls
which is ended up going viral has now
run into a spot of copyright bother
goldieblox original video featured a
group of young girls singing about
coding and building spaceships in a
parody of a popular Beastie Boys song
well for obvious reasons we can't show
you it now but it racked up over eight
million views on YouTube the band say
they support the empowerment of young
girls but they won't permit their music
we used in product ads well after the
release of the xbox one and the
PlayStation 4 we are a little bit
consoled out here at swank so in this
week's gaming review we decided to take
a look at some of the handheld releases
IGN's Daniel Cooper has been talking us
through some of the top titles for the
Nintendo 3ds and the PS Vita
so for the 3d ass I think probably won
the games of the year is zelda a link
between two worlds now if you've ever
played the 90 91 classic a Link to the
Past this might have a strong and
nostalgic pull for you
it's very much in the tradition of Zelda
games it's a heroic quest with lots of
puzzle solving but it takes that very
kind of tried and tested formula and
puts it on its head samrat so even if
you played love zelda games you'll still
find it surprising and unexpected and
like those are the games it's
stimulating and just one the best games
of the year for me anyway the other big
3ds game is pokemon X&Y now Pokemon has
been around for years but again this is
one that kind of I don't know can
reinvigorate the series it's moved it
into the 3d world it sounded kind of
Parisian landscape but it's hard still
Pokemon and that formula still as
compelling as ever you go around
collecting your creatures you raise them
you nurture them and then you pit them
against each other and that core
mechanic that core journey is still very
very powerful and lovely
playstation vita also has great games of
its own not only does it let you stream
games from your playstation 4 it has
some games are really truly exceptional
this Christmas and you've got tearaway
now I absolutely loved her away it's a
3d platformer with this kind of like
puzzle solving but it's from the people
who made a little big planet so it's
again that really celebrates creativity
storytelling and imagination which are
bad things when you're kind of sick of
guns and games so it's a game that's set
in a world that's looks like it's made
out of paper and paper crafts so
everyone's made out a thick card and
tracing paper and so on and it uses the
Vita a unique array of input senses
touch screen the cameras so when you're
playing with this world it feels like
you're actually touching it even if you
touch the rear pad your fingers kind of
break through the paper and appear in
the game so it's a gaming experience
that I can't really imagine being on any
of the platform
you're the game on PlayStation Vita
that's definitely worth checking out is
flower now this came out a few years ago
on playstation 3 and it's kind of unlike
any other gaming experience how their
this from the people who made journey
last year and it's similar sort of
poetic kind of ethereal game where you
play the wind and you guide petals in a
landscape bringing back life to a
monochromatic landscape it's truly
beautiful really soothing very relaxing
and I guarantee you've probably never
played anything like it
well that's a lot for this week remember
you can catch up with a breaking text or
nice or week on sky knees for iPad or
smartphone apps and sky news com we'll
see you next time